Puerto Rico's governor ricardo sao has
announced his resignation after days of
mass protests in that US territory
versão said he would continue working
until August second to allow an orderly
transition he's been at the center of a
text message messaging scandal that has
already led top officials to resign the
leaked messages revealed him mocking his
constituents and contained sexist
profane and homophobic remarks earlier I
spoke with DWS correspondent Alexander
phenom who's in the capital San Juan who
gave us the people were together waiting
for his announcement in front of his
mansion but only tonight very late he
finally announced that he would step
down the peace
main office until the 2nd of August to
make sure that there will be an ordinary
transition and when people here watch
the panel and learn that he is really
going to step down they were
celebrates to dance in the street to
drive their cars throughout the city to
wave flags our will be happy can you
tell us what it was that angered the
public so much that led to the mass
protests where you are and to the
resignation of the US territories
governor
yeah on Sunday he was talking about that
it is important for him to stay in
office to stay in power because what he
has achieved for the island but it
became clear that he didn't have any
other choice than to step down after
internal telegram messages were leaked
messages text messages in which the
governor made misogynist and homophobic
comments he mocked victims of Hurricane
Maria
he made jokes about shooting San Juan
Samir and basically all of that people
have felt that it was so disgusting
that the Spartans started to protest and
as the protests continued so they drew
the pressure on the governor to step
down okay he says he's going to step
down on on August second tour the
protesters accepting that and what about
the the transition are the people in
place that that Puerto Rico needs to to
deal with all the problems that's facing
and there are many problems indeed each
the island is dealing with so people
that I talk to here on the streets told
me that they think it is their a
Victorian that there are satisfied that
he is stepping down he himself said that
he has to stay in office until August
second to make sure that there will be a
good transition his Secretary of Justice
is going to take over however we have to
say as you mentioned that Puerto Rico
has a lot of problems they had a serious
of corruption scandals they are still
recovering from eureka eureka maria they
went through a long recession and they
had to declare bankruptcy and are still
waiting for a new political class people
here in san juan told me alexander
thanks for bringing us up-to-date live
from San Juan Puerto Rico thank you very
much